[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter labelle
according to secretary of state lincoln
china is the only country with the
economic
military and technological power to
seriously challenge
the stable and open international system
all of the rules
values and relationships that make the
world work
the way we want it to is china really a
threat to washington's
global system
[Music]
discuss these issues and more i'm joined
by my guest seth corpsley in washington
he is the senior fellow and director at
the center of american sea power at
hudson institute
also in washington we have surah gupta
he is asia pacific international
relations specialist
at the institute for china american
studies and in london we cross to winnie
king she is a policy analyst and senior
lecturer
in chinese international political
economy all right crosstalk roles in
effect that means you can jump in
anytime you want
and i always appreciate it let's go to
seth in washington
i found blinken's statements about china
quite remarkable because
basically what he said is that and he
didn't say in
complete words but basically the
international system that the united
states has built since the second world
war
designed by the united states directed
by the united states
everyone must conform to it and china
must too
and if it doesn't conform to it then
that's how they define the threat
is that a fair thing to say seth no
that's not what lincoln said
like what i ordered him in the beginning
my introduction
what lincoln said was that the
international order
as exists right now um and
as with which the united states has been
uh
a party to along with other democratic
countries
is under threat by china and what the
chinese call
everything with chinese characteristics
so that means that free trade
freedom of navigation um
uh certainly free enterprise uh a
non-mercantilist system
uh one where there is uh
something like multilateral cooperation
uh
on trade and where there is not an
acceptance of
uh intellectual property theft wholesale
um that that's the kind of world the
united states seeks to
preserve and increase um not to enforce
upon others
which have been barely
[Music]
and lincoln is saying is that china is
challenging it well
i mean it is a multipolar world right
now
one party doesn't make the rules or
shouldn't make the rules because then it
will cause conflict winning let me go to
you
i mean it it seems to me number one the
world that the us
is the architecture that the u.s has
been at the
at the meeting since the second world
war hugely benefited china china likes a
lot of those rules okay
uh so you know i i think also during
that
after the second world war all the way
up to now the united states has never
really had a peer so it has to start
thinking about how the international
international order is going to exist
with a pure power go ahead winnie
i would agree with you china has
benefited a lot from the current
neoliberal order
and in that in that respect it's it's
not in china's interest to change it or
to challenge it
i think um lincoln's statement in his
speech because i read the speech
it's it's very interesting in two
significant ways
one is that it suggests that america is
a lone war
and that it's a towering nation
basically trying to
to uh fight against the growing um
influence of the chinese communist party
this obviously isn't true
china is not able to challenge um
america
militarily effectively not only in its
region not only because the fact that
america has a lot of allies and it has
nato
but when it comes to economics china has
worked
according to the rules of the game that
has been set out for it it is still
considered a developing economy
um and therefore a lot of the demands
that america putting on china
at this time are demands that we require
of a developed department so what
america really should be doing is
reassessing its status um that's the
place
to begin i think it's also important
really to highlight that um what the
speech really
really emphasizes is the fact that in
emphasizing and prioritizing
american values and the interests of the
american people
is that you're not no longer going with
the idea that this is
a a international system that's
that um we're looking at after world war
ii
this is a system that actually is very
trump s
it's following 2016. and so the game is
very much
changed you know lincoln you know also
you know he talked to i'm glad when he
brought it up because i stopped in my
introduction
how it benefited the american people
absolutely right that was a continuation
of it
but seth i mean china also has its
national interests it has to look after
its own people
i mean why can't the chinese do what
what
uh washington wants to do for its own
people china will do for its own i mean
it seems to me it's like our party and
if you want to if you want to
participate you have to do exactly what
we say but the united states doesn't
own the international order it's a
member of the international order
uh you know the real dilemma out here
for the united states
is that china is more or less
playing by the rules of the game that
the united states laid down
and china playing by those same rules is
going to go
vastly ahead of the united states in
terms of
material capabilities particularly
economic size
just think about it this way in a couple
of decades hence
if china gets to the level of
productivity that south korea is at
today
china will china's economy will be two
and a half times the size of the united
states
playing by the rules of the game that
the united states laid down
china will be way ahead of the united
states and this creates a fundamental
dilemma
of how to manage china and the problem
has been
that china does not want to change the
setup because it works
more or less pretty well for china but
for the united states
something needs to change in strategy
and that's not yet
figured out how to change that in
strategy and so instead we have this
doubling down in rhetoric
that china is cheating china's doing
this blah blah blah blah blah
trying to create a coalition against
china but the fact of the matter
is one needs to have a better criteria
one needs to have better accusations
against china to be
able to create that coalition against
china and that's not working and
i think this is to some extent
frustration and fear at the u.s
end and that should not be the case
because china
as as we just said is just still an
upper middle
income economy and it is not a given
that the chinese communist party will be
there forever
that's not been the case in taiwan the
way authoritarian systems have come down
it could happen in china and we could
have a much more pluralized setup at
some point of time in the next couple of
decades and a decade or two
and that could completely change the
conversation so the u.s needs to stay
true to its values
and observe the rules of the system that
it itself laid down
and of course hold others to the other's
feet to the fire too
so that they too do so the same seth you
want to reply to that go ahead
well yeah uh i'm
wondering whether uh the clashes on the
border between china
and india constitute uh
adherence to the international order
that um
the other guests are saying the united
states has sat down
uh that doesn't strike me as the
um it's the kind of order that uh either
the united states or any other
democratic country or non-democratic
country would want
yeah but what should the united states
do if there was a conflict between
india and china what should the united
states do i don't think that the
that statesmen have the luxury of
making plans based on what could or what
might happen
i think one has to look at what is
actually happening
and judged by that uh china
represents a threat to the national the
international order of the liberal
international
order so what to try to do seth
what what should try to do and you and
mr blinken what should china do
just uh uh agree to any kind of demand
from washington
i don't think that agreeing to demands
from washington has anything to do with
how the chinese treat the uyghurs in
their own country
or threaten taiwan with force or have
clashes with the
with the indians on their uh on their
northern what should the united states
do about that go to war with china
no of course not okay okay go
winnie go ahead jump in i think what
seth what you're suggesting
is number one that you that america
wants
china to just say you know what you're
right i i i'm listening to you you are
the leader of the international system
and we will take it on board what you're
saying and adapt
um i think that there's a bit of
there's a bit of hypocrisy in that when
we're talking about the fact that number
one
with regards to china and india the
border clashes
they have been they've been having
territorial issues for decades
and they have had clashes on and off for
decades and they have resolved
at least for now what's going to be what
you know how they want to deal with the
situation
we're going to talk about um certain
clashes that are potentially
contradictory to the rules of the
international order you could call out
what america is doing in other countries
particularly in the middle east
um and i'm not saying i want to take it
there but if we're going to fold china
if america wants to hold china to the
rules of the international order
it then it's necessary for america to
hold itself to the rules of the
international world
if we're safe as you said america is not
the leader america is not trying to
control everything it is just
part of the system yeah it's not a
question
of holding china to the rules of the
american order uh it's a question of
what sort of order
exists in the world the united states is
not able to do this by itself
and the fact that the threat to the
international order
is recognized not simply by the united
states but by europe
as well is demonstrated by the fact that
the british are sending a carrier strike
group to the south china sea
the french are sending a submarine the
germans the germans are sending a
surface ship
and so there's a growing awareness of
what china's aggressiveness
and ambition global ambitions mean not
just for the united
states but for europe as well and i
expect that that will continue
in washington uh sort of gupta is china
a military threat
i mean why are the british going all the
way around the world to
to the south china sea which as far as i
know as uh
the where china is the south china sea
is called that for a reason here
i mean um it seems to me that we're
seeing so much of a
military response i mean is i would
think that's the kind of the last thing
you would want to uh
be presenting what there's so many
things you in diplomacy so that you can
have before that
i mean whatever that does is all that
all that does is
trying to react military let's go to our
other guests in washington mr gupta go
ahead
you know the perfect point out here
one talks about globally expansionist
in terms of china being doing this this
globally and then
all the issues that we talk about are
frankly right at its periphery
in which some in many of which it has
fairly pretty legitimate claims
i mean before i come to the south china
sea you think about the india
china india border dispute actually
china prior to what happened on the
border had
put forth a boundary resolution proposal
with regard to a certain segment of the
boundary
what did the indians do the indians
instead went and declared that kashmir
was a union territory now the you know
kashmir has
a certain area which is also disputed
with china when china does these things
everybody jumps to the sky when
when when the other countries do well
i'm sorry i have to jump in here we have
to go to a heart break and after that
heartbreak
more discussion on u.s china relations
stay with our tips
[Music]
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things were considered i'm peter lavelle
to remind you we're talking about the
u.s
china relationship
[Music]
okay let's go back to mr gupta in
washington dc you were talking about
perceptions of chinese aggression go
right ahead
yeah exactly perceptions of of chinese
aggression
you know let's let's be clear about it
you know the chinese are
clause in terms of the way they handle
many of these territorial aspects
a force is an extension of diplomacy and
politics but force within certain
limits this is not force which is going
to be used
on the other side of the world and for
bases etc et cetera
it's a very limited use of force and
there's limited use of forces done more
for political reasons
think about it in term from 1979 to 2021
china has had little bit of all its
claustrophenol
movements on its territorial fronts
we've had less than 150 casualties
those last 40 years now think about it
with regard to the illegal wars if how
many zeros we have to add to that
in terms of casualties but let me get to
a larger point out here
with regard to china uh again china is
very territoriality oriented
and therefore china is not a military
threat to the world
per se but in terms within those first
island chain and the second island chain
in the western pacific china has
very serious territorial claims and and
strategic interests
and and in regard to those interests it
will
ensure that there is an anti-access
anti-denial strategy
with regard to prosecuting a conflict or
contingency which
might arise within in these waters but
that also means that
beyond these geographies there is
actually
no basis whatsoever for china to be
involved in a hot conflict
and that includes places like the south
pacific or the string of pearls in the
indian ocean
there is no question of conflict
military conflict happening
out there but there is obviously with
taiwan it is a flash point
and we can see that the conflict is
potentially possible out there
so again there's it's it's a it's a
qualified answer in terms of
military it's not a military threat to
the world but that has military
interests and there is a potential
for a very serious clash of those in
those areas hey seth you're the odd man
out so i'd like you to reply to what we
just heard go ahead well uh
you know this is uh there's a certain
amount of speculation here which is
understandable
um but when the question is asked
or when it's asserted that china is not
a threat globally
that may or may not be true but i think
that it's important to look
at what kinds of ships
the chinese are building because ships
are the way that you
the principal way for a country to
project power
china is working on uh is
working on laying the keel for its
fourth
uh aircraft carrier which will be a very
large aircraft carrier and very modern
one with electromagnetic
catapults and all the attributes of a
of a modern ship um you don't need
four aircraft carriers for the south
china sea
you need aircraft carriers for one
reason alone and that's to project power
how you use the power that's the
question for speculation
the pacific is a pretty big place okay
but to say that china is not a threat
globally and is merely concerned with
regional issues
uh is believed by the fact of building
amphibious ships which are meant to
project power
and building aircraft carriers in
increasing numbers which are meant to do
the same thing
okay india is building three aircraft
carriers don't say india already has
they will have three aircraft carriers
by 2030. i don't hear anybody saying
india is being expansionist and going to
south america and going to conquer
somebody
so i mean we need to have a little bit
of fairness
in this in in in the context of this
debate frankly
let me go to any here in london but when
if you know we just we have the quad you
know we have uh
uh in that's being um um
it's being designed at least by some
people in washington to be kind of an
asia nato obviously to contain china
and so i mean when you see this
containment policy
being encircled um encouraging the quad
to econo
to militarily cooperate which i i find
really problematic i
i don't i just can't see how the
australians are going to get involved
with it
a dispute the south koreans have with
the uh with with china
and you think you know south korea is
going to really come to the aid of japan
i doubt that too
okay but i mean if you it it's this this
containment
is real okay we have ships you know
going into the region here okay
and and obviously making it clear they
see
uh this is all um projecting power
against china
not for freedom of the seas but you know
they're keeping their eye out on
one target in one target only go ahead
winnie
so the idea of chinese containment has
began in the 1990s
um after after you see the fall of the
soviet union
you still have this major communist
power within within the world
okay um the rise of the chinese economy
naturally
raises more concerns with the americans
as to what it might mean for the region
where you have japan
which is a major ally for the americans
um as well as south korea when you're
concerned about what it might mean for
north korea and the korean peninsula
do you think we need to think about when
it comes to the idea of
china as a military threat is the bigger
picture there's three aspects you need
to look at
offensive power defensive power and the
idea of china as
a major military power in terms of arms
exports right
um what we're talking about with seth
raised with the fact that china is
trying to develop its fourth aircraft
carrier
america has 43. so offensively
yes china's idea of china being a major
uh military power is growing but
it's in terms of challenging america
it's exaggerated
defensive power this is not exaggerated
in terms of the fact that you can see as
mr gupta says how china is prioritizing
its concerns and its its uh presence in
the region
it is fundamentally focusing on defense
of power
trying to ensure that nothing happens
with regards to the wrath of taiwan
the curing the physician with regards to
the cell tendency in the east china sea
because it is key that you have the
trading routes
through the malacca straits this is one
of the reasons why we have the beltway
initiative
because china recognizes that the idea
of chinese containment
is going to prioritize a potential risk
with regards to trade routes so
therefore you need the cross management
and there's a growing discussion about
air routes right
when it comes to armed exports america
naturally as we expect
is the world's leading exporter of arms
in 2020 for china it exports
9 billion per year over the last decade
it is not a challenge
in that in that sense so in the big
picture
yes china i can see why there are
concerns
but it's regional fundamentally regional
in terms of
where china is trying to protect its
interests so mr gupta's point about
territoriality
absolutely china's never wavered from
day one about what his concerns are
let me go back to you i mean it seems to
me you know
the the rise of china uh on the
international scene has been
actually spectacular if you look at the
course of history i mean
unbelievable um and if i can just
really give a really broad picture here
i mean this is the first time in 500
years that a non-european
power is becoming appear with the
only single superpower in the world this
is what blinken is talking about
i find it really insulting it's all
couched in values and democracy
considering all of the illegal wars that
the united states participated in
in this century alone okay i mean it's
just because
china is becoming a peer and nobody in
washington understands how to deal with
that
and because it's this whole
exceptionalist of nonsense starts short
circuiting because there's someone else
out there that is
growing in power and there's really
nothing they can do about it and that's
why they default back on these
ephemeral things that you know i think
are hypocritical if you look at
american foreign policy and nato also go
ahead mr cooper
no no you're perfectly correct on that
on that front you know
the fact that we are going to have a
non-western power which is going to be
sitting atop the mountain or somewhere
thereabouts is the fact
that is very hard to digest because the
word that we live in
is written has been written uh by the
judeo-christian west frankly and it's
it's it's not
it's absolutely not easy to accept that
that fact
uh the chinese have been an immense far
in the past they're coming back to that
to that in in to being that that sort of
power
and they're doing it at a time when the
rest of the world or at least and
certainly asia per
person is rising and doing very well so
this is
a rise unlike japan where it happened at
the expense of asia
it's happening with asia and that that
makes it that much more harder
and that's why i mean even india's
priorities here are pretty questionable
i
do not take it for granted that india is
just stuck in the quad let me explain
in 2019 the uh the the pacific
forces commander naval commander said
you know what we need to kind of quit on
the squad business because it's not
really going anywhere
because the indian naval head of the
indian naval
uh command had told him like you know
what we're really not too much keen
about this squad business
because india and china were doing
having a good relationship at that point
of time
and of course relations have gone down
and suddenly the quarter has gone up and
it might just go the other way around
but coming back to china i think the
important takeaway from china and i
is to in terms of its rises not so much
to focus just on the military element
you know the lesson the chinese learn
from 2 000 years of conflict with their
periphery is
that it is not worth trying to squash
your enemy because you will not be able
to do that
better to play to their avarice and
greed
and try to find divisions within them
and that is what china is going to do as
a 50 trillion 70
trillion dollar economy it is going to
find differences within branches of the
west
as it did with branches of the mongols
and therefore
that is the one thing where the west
needs to be needs to get its game
together and frankly as we're seeing out
here
the comprehensive agreement on
investment if china is willing to play
by those rules advanced country rules
and
industrial subsidies the europeans are
willing to say hey let's we
are ready to shake hands and we need to
then answer what happens then in that
case where are you going with that
well i think i think that's very
interesting i'll go to seth for the last
uh
question here i mean it's the
neoliberalism what the us did was
financialize its economy
you know just gut the the
industrialization part of it and the
chinese embrace a very different
neoliberalism
they're the the factory of the world and
they make all kinds of things we saw
this you know with these
uh um production chains during the uh
the the ongoing crisis here
i mean yeah they've embraced
neo-liberalism and come out on the
winning side
when the middle class in america came
out on the losing side with the same
ideology go ahead seth
well of course the
contest between nations uh
is not it certainly should not be
considered in terms of
military balance or economics but rather
the combination of the two and the claim
that was made a moment ago by by what
i think by winnie about the defensive
character
of uh china's regional policy
is blind by the their treatment of the
of the filipinos of the indonesians of
the vietnamese
of the japanese of their threat to use
force to take taiwan
those are not the things i'm sorry i
have to jump in here lebron out of time
i'm
sincerely apologize for interrupting
that's all the time we have i want to
thank my guests in washington washington
and in london i want to thank our
viewers for watching the crt see you
next time remember
crosstalk rules